Matthew its Ross Tucker filling in for
Dan today on the Dan Patrick show is it
a coincidence that you're doing this
radio tour on the day the NHL playoff
starts it is a total coincidence and I'm
really bummed to be in London during the
playoffs cuz I'm gonna miss the games oh
man why are you over there I wrote a
play called the end of longing that
there's been going up here in the West
End of London and we'll be we're gonna
do it until May 14th and we started
rehearsals January 4th so I've been here
for quite a while that's awesome now I
don't know anything about plays other
than my wife loves and we go to Broadway
shows here in New York why London is
that in New York well that's where they
bought it they but they bought it here
and it will go to New York next May
and we're gonna perform it next May in
New York so you're not gonna get a
chance to watch your beloved NHL
playoffs as much who is I know you're
from Ottawa they didn't make it
obviously who's your squad who do you
want to see win well my favorite sports
team is the LA King so I followed them
and hope that they do well pretty cool
how much success they've had reasons but
it's been a good time to be a fan huh
yeah they're a good team and I followed
them around during their first Stanley
Cup run in 2012 and I went to the road
games and flew myself down there to st.
Louis and in New Jersey and went to all
the games
that's awesome we're talking with
Matthew Perry he stars as Oscar Madison
and CBS is The Odd Couple you're in
season two right now Matthew how big a
deal is it when after season one they
pick it up for another year I'm is that
like an athlete getting a contract
extension that I would imagine that
that's a great feeling well it gave us
an opportunity to make the show better
which it did become much better the
second season is much better season of
television than the first season was I
would say actually our worst episode
this year is better than our best
episode
last year the writing just sort of
gelled and we all sort of gelled as a
cast and it's just a much better season
of television so I'm excited about it
and we had some really interesting guest
stars come on this year Oscar Madison
was looking for a true relationship of
depth this season and he found it in
teri hatcher who was on the show she's
did about four or five episodes and she
was wonderful and funny and terrific and
fun to be around and Garry Marshall is
also on the show this year he's not just
an executive consultant he plays Oscar
Madison's father in probably my favorite
episode of the year and he got familiar
with Garry Marshall yeah I've heard of
Garry Marshall absolutely yeah he was
the executive editor of the original
series and has been around as an
executive consultant on the show and he
played Oscar Madison's father this year
and he speaks so slowly that the script
that week instead of being about 50
pages long was about 14 pages long you
know I'm curious I'm sure you've been
asked this a million times especially
last year when it was season one but how
much do you watch of the movie or the
old show and how how much of a challenge
is that for you as opposed to so many
other gigs you've had over the years
where it's something starting fresh well
I wrote the pilot for the show so it was
a challenge to try to keep some of the
old stuff and bring some new stuff and
modernized the show I was a huge fan of
the movie at probably in the movie 30 or
35 times so I was very familiar with it
and we actually used some jokes in the
pilot from the movie and they held up
and we're very funny 45 years later so
the challenge was to modernize the show
while keeping the same dynamic between
the two characters which is really the
heart of the show the difference between
Felix Unger and Oscar Madison and how
they fight and battle and have arguments
and that's really where the show is that
its strongest talking with Matthew Perry
he stars as Oscar Madison and CBS is the
a couple it's in season two right now
tomorrow night 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
Oscar and MuRF decide to throw a big
bash like the old days you mentioned
Matthew about you know the writing and
the cast gelling obviously when your
name comes up a lot of people still
think friends and and bring up friends
you know having a show that popular
what's the best part about it and what's
the worst part about it now that you're
you know 10 plus years removed from it
well the best part of it is it continues
to open doors for me and allow me to do
projects that I want to do like The Odd
Couple and the play that I'm doing now
and none of that would be happening if
it wasn't for friends so that's the best
part and the worst part is walking down
the street and hearing yo-chan last part
it's funny that you say that because you
know 94 to 2004 Matthew was my sophomore
year of high school through my fourth
year in the NFL
I really bothered me that David
Schwimmer's character Ross was the type
of person that he was in terms of kind
of a whiny it just because my first
name's Ross and it just I it was sort of
the antithesis of what I wanted to be
have you had Chandler's come up to you
ever in life and talk about the impact
your you're playing that role had on how
people look at them or that name when
people think Chandler was there a lot of
people have named their children
Chandler which is very flattering
so there's a lot of little babies and
toddlers out there named Chandler the
strange thing that's happening now is
because the shows on Netflix we have a
whole new set of fans that are much
younger and 13 and 14 year old kids are
coming up to me and wondering why I look
so old that is awesome what um I read
where you were a big tennis player
growing up yes I played a lot of tennis
which would you have rather been a star
tennis player a star athlete or a star
actor like you became well I think the
grass was always greener so I think it
would be would have been wonderful to be
a Wimbledon champion and to be a
professional tennis player but I've had
a very fortunate life in show business
so things are going well so I'm very I
feel very lucky what was it like growing
up in Canada where everybody's a hockey
player being a tennis player well I was
I was playing hockey as well oh I wasn't
as good a hockey player as I was a
tennis player but I was playing a lot of
hockey too because you have to play
hockey when you grow up in Canada right
so it wasn't like all the other kids in
school that were hockey guys are like
yeah look at look at Matthew the tennis
player like that you were still playing
hockey you were still serving your
country by playing high I was still
serving my country by playing hockey yes
Matthew really appreciate the time
congratulations not only on the second
season of The Odd Couple but getting to
play sold like you did you got your
hands on a lot of different things
that's fantastic
thank you very much the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience